[Music]
hello everyone i'm faye associate
producer welcome to this new video about
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
today our heroes travel to terraflora in
their quest to save the sparks
this green and usually flurry planet is
struck by a drought caused by curses
malevolent influence
go now
[Music]
to help the planet blossom again mario
and his friends must reach the top of
the volcano to get there they will have
to find their way to the central station
and take the wiggler train
terror flora like all the planets of
mario prescribing sparks of hope is
packed with secrets collectibles to
gather puzzles to solve and wacky npcs
to talk with
with the help of people heroes can
interact with the environment in various
ways to uncover secrets or reveal a
hidden path to new zones
there are many interesting places to
visit and secrets to discover on
terraflora
giant trees lush plains and hidden caves
but let's get back on track
we have a train to catch
[Music]
all aboard
[Music]
[Music]
oh
the waver has been enraged by cursa and
we must stop it before it destroys the
train
[Music]
mario and his friends will face numerous
enemy archetypes on the battlefield each
with specific strengths and weaknesses
we need to prepare accordingly
let's speak bowser first his huge health
stats will allow him to sustain heavy
damage
rabbit rosalina's signature technique
will be key to neutralize enemies while
the other heroes focus on the darkness
eyes will keep mario and the team to
take advantage of his great mobility
skills
now the sparks there are dozens of
sparks you can pair with new heroes they
will grant elemental damage resistances
help control battlefield and much more
ethering will help robert rosalina
getting behind enemy lines to wreak
havoc
we're done prepping so now is the time
to fight
let's activate mario spark aqua knox to
gain additional splash damage
thanks to the splash effect mario can
push the ooze out of the train why he
destroyed the electric barrel with his
second attack
[Music]
rabbit rosalina can finish the ooze off
[Music]
while bowser takes advantage of the
large attack radius of his bouzouka to
destroy two darkness eyes at the same
time
fast forward new enemies are spawning
behind us
we must get rid of them quickly
let's use mario spark glitter to lure
those enemies out into the open before
triggering mario's signature abilities
hero side
it's time for bowser to get his revenge
his landing damage ability
combined with the devastating power of
zephyr break his shockwave spark and
mario's support fire will make short
work of this group of enemies
teamwork and synergies are key to gain
the upper hand in battle
now that the back of the train is clear
we must reach the locomotive to destroy
the darkness eyes on the wiggler's back
this won't be easy as the lone wolves
will react by shooting any moving hero
coming into range
they inflict heavy damage to bowser
thankfully exosphere his shield spark
absorbs some of the damage
brute force won't make it here it's time
for a stealthy move with rory rosalino
her spark ethering can turn her
invisible allowing her to approach the
lone wolf safely
now that we are close to them we can use
the signature technique and neutralize
them momentarily
this will allow mario to approach safely
and focus on the darkness eyes
a few more turns have passed only two
darkness eyes remain but new powerful
enemies have spawned and even bowser
cannot withstand their powerful attacks
we have only two heroes left and the
last darkness eyes are far out of attack
range but mario can count on his iconic
stump attack and jump from one enemy to
the other before delivering the final
blow
this is it the wiggler is defeated and
our heroes can resume their journey i
hope you enjoyed this very special
battle that's all for now
[Music]
so
[Music]
you